the jurgen experience we were talking
before
this there's so much to talk about but
we were talking before and you were
saying that uh
over the last year you almost died
because you had some crazy internal and
uh
you had an aneurysm in your pancreas is
that where you said it was yeah i had an
undiagnosed asymptomatic aneurysm which
is a
sort of ballooning in the blood vessel
uh in the artery
in my pancreatic artery and out of the
blue it was a congenital thing like i
apparently
had developed during my whole life it um
it was just from a
a structural problem and uh and one
afternoon one beautiful june afternoon
last year at first
and um you know i just felt this pain
shoot through my stomach i was like damn
what is that
within a few minutes i couldn't stand up
and within about 10 minutes i would
start to go blind
and my wife called them the ambulance
and um those guys got there and and um
you know i was tanking
really fast and the hospital is an hour
away
and i said by a miracle i don't even
think the doctors understand it but by a
miracle i was still alive when i got to
the hospital i lost 90
of my blood into my abdomen um
and um i didn't know i was dying but i
was dying
and i was right in that sort of twilight
zone
and um the uh a black
pit opened up underneath me and i felt
myself starting to get pulled down into
it and i
i didn't want to go like it was cold and
dark and black and bottomless and i just
knew
like do not go down there i was getting
pulled down into it and right at that
moment
my father who passed away in 2012
my father sort of appeared next to me
and started
trying to communicate trying to
communicate with me and comforting me
and i um i sort of waved him away and
the last thing i remember saying to the
doctor i was sort of losing
consciousness and the
last thing i said to the doctor was
you're losing me right now you got to
hurry
he was trying to put it he'd cut my neck
open he was trying to put a line into my
neck
you know they pumped ten ten units of
blood into me and that's what brought me
back
it was really close
wow um when you say you you felt like
you're you were sinking into a pit
like do you seeing this yeah i mean
you know your perceptions are very weird
because i you know very little oxygen in
the brain i had a
hemoglobin count of 1.2 if you're a
doctor you know what that is it's almost
unheard of
and so i just felt this pit underneath
me and it was pulling me into it and i
didn't want to go
and you can see a pit yeah i mean again
c
feel your perceptions are very weird
when you're like that and then my father
also was sort of floating above me he
was a presence
i don't know if seeing him is quite the
word
it's another perception wow
yeah so coming out of that
once you regained your health you must
have had an incredible newfound
appreciation for all the people in your
life and just
everything it was a long path you know i
mean i'm a really healthy guy
later the doctor said you know it was
your you know i was a marathon runner
when i was young and
um i don't drink i'm i am athletic
and i use my body pretty vigorously and
he said that saved your life
like you didn't have a heart attack like
you you you owe your life to that
wow but the next morning you know i
didn't know that i'd almost died
i had no idea i have two little girls i
have a four year old and a one and a
half year old and they're the most
precious things to me
i mean i can't even describe it
obviously
and the fact that they almost lost their
dad was just devastating when the icu
nurse
came in and said how are you doing mr
younger
you're one lucky guy you almost died
yesterday i had no idea
and then she came back an hour later and
um
and she said how are you doing and i
said you know physically and i was
throwing up blood i was
i'm not i was not doing very well
physically but i said i was
i said but you know i'm really
struggling with what you told me and
um it's really terrifying i didn't know
and i mean i said i almost died in my
own driveway in front of my family
and i didn't even know like and i said i
keep thinking about it i can't stop
and she said the wisest things
one of the wisest things i've ever heard
she said um
she said stop thinking of that moment as
scary and start thinking of it as sacred
and she didn't elaborate she didn't need
to and the next five days in the icu i
thought about
the word sacred and what the experience
was now giving me access to
and you know not to sound sort of like
trite but
um life is a freaking miracle and you
know i'm not religious
i you know whatever i i don't think any
of us
few of us i certainly didn't quite
understand
um what a miracle it is that we're alive
that we exist
that we draw breath that we can think
about ourselves that we're here for even
one day
is a freaking miracle and you can forget
that
because your life gets busy and all of a
sudden
i feel like life was sort of returned to
me meaning that i understood how
sacred it is and um again i'm an atheist
i don't mean sacred in a religious sense
i mean in the sense that it's has a
profound value
and you mustn't mustn't forget
it's so easy to lose sight of that when
you're caught up in your bills or
traffic or you [ __ ] and
yeah there's so much so much of life
that is
essential in in in order for you to just
keep on
existing in society but not really
important
yeah and you know we're humans we're i
mean you know we're wired to react to
things you know someone pisses you off
or you're tired
it's not that we shouldn't have those
reactions those reactions also keep us
alive i mean
our emotional physical reactions are
adaptive and they protect us
right but at the end of the day you
don't want them to run away with your
experience of life
you want to reclaim it and just go right
you know
all i have to do is go back to that
moment of
what happened in that driveway and that
i was spared getting pulled into that
pit
that didn't happen and my daughters get
to have a father
i get to experience whatever the rest of
my life is
whatever it is who knows how long i'll
live but i get i i that gift was
returned to me
um and i don't even know i don't even
know who to say thank you to
other than i've started giving blood 10
10 people
10 people donated blood and saved my
life i'll never know who they are
and that um you know it makes you part
of this sort of
web of life um in a way that it's
you know what i gave blood for the first
time you know like after this happened i
gave blood and i made me feel so good
uh and now i've i can't wait to do it
again like you're i'm part of something
bigger and
and that's one of the most profound
human joys is to be part of something
greater than yourself
so this this experience um that
you how long did it take you before you
were fully recovered well you know i had
i had a you know gallon of blood in my
abdomen and and
a gallon well whatever that amount of
blood in your body gets out something
like that they can't you know it's a
hematoma and my
body had to gradually reabsorb it so
you know that takes months and uh and
now i'm left with this sort of
psychological residue of the experience
which is i have this um
uh you know renewed reinvigorated
appreciation for life
um but also the
the truth about life is that none of us
know for sure we're gonna be alive
at sunset you know i mean we all know
you can get cancer
you can die in a car accident or
whatever but really the truth is
the thing we're we're alive because the
tiniest membranes in your body
are are are not rupturing you know what
i mean like the system that your body is
is like incredibly complex and if
something goes wrong
you can be dead in minutes and you can
be totally healthy and that can happen
and the fact that the universe can just
randomly take you out
for um no apparent reason um
that's pretty startling news if you
think about it i didn't know it worked
that way
and it can make you kind of paranoid did
it make you paranoid no totally yeah
i mean i just every day i was like i
mean this was gradually going away
but i just i realized like you don't
know you just don't know that you're
going to be alive in an
hour from now and you're going running
you're
you're reading a book to your daughter
or whatever having dinner with some
friends and
now i like an hour from now i could be
dead or the guy i'm talking to could be
dead and none of us
know and none of us can do anything
about it and that's just what life is
we're
we're living on a rock hurtling through
the universe i mean we're
we're part of the universe and we exist
that it's
um and it's mercy really
were you afterwards contemplating what
that pit was
and what it means and what it means to
slide into that and like
you know i started to do a little
research into the
the death i want to write a book about
this i think i'm going to call it pulse
oh i like that the thing that keeps us
alive it's a good name
and why we're alive and what happens
when you die
and i've just started doing some
research into this and and
the the the the visitation by dead
ancestors is very common
for people um and often um
i mean there's all kinds of reasons that
you might hallucinate when your brain's
low on oxygen
but you know i didn't hallucinate anyone
in my family i didn't
lose i hallucinated my dead father right
and that's very very common and i didn't
know i was dying
so it's not like i conjured him up
because i knew i was headed somewhere
i was very confused and there he was
trying to comfort me and that's a really
common experience so i looked into it
and so they have they have all these you
know release of ketamine and all
like they have all these dmt and they
have all these sort of neurochemical
explanations
for the subjective experience of dying
for the person and we only know this
because people come back like i do and
report
what they saw and it's usually pretty
weird but it's
pretty weird in predictable ways like a
lot of people see the dead
it's as if they show up to help and
i want to repeat i'm an atheist i'm not
religious i don't believe in anything
my dad was a physicist so i want to sort
of explain what happens in ways that he
would
respect scientifically and so one of the
things they said
is that you can take low oxygen kind of
mean
all these things that physically could
happen in the brain you can you can
subject a healthy person to those things
and they don't have the same kinds of
hallucinations
those hallucinations are particular only
to the dying
and i want to know i want to try to
figure out what
is going on in that weird twilight space
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience